bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en compagnie de
michaël szames s bonjour micro placé
pour public sénat emmanuel clair nous
allons donc passer en revue ensemble
l'actualité de la semaine marquée bien
sûr par le départ du président moubarak
après trente ans de pouvoir
jeudi soir il annoncé seulement délégué
ses fonctions au vice-président égyptien
il a finalement cédé à la pression de la
rue et quitter le pouvoir d'une semaine
marquée aussi par le mécontentement du
monde de la justice
ulcéré par les critiques de nicolas
sarkozy semaine ponctuée par des reports
d'audiences dans presque tous les
tribunaux de france est une grande
manifestation ce jeudi notamment à noms
dont était parti le mouvement
enfin nicolas sarkozy et son rendez vous
face au français deux heures et demie de
discussion télévisé avec un panel de
neuf personnes employées des mesures
contre la délinquance des mineurs au
chantier de la dépendance
l'émission a rassemblé 8 millions de
téléspectateurs un peu moins que l'année
dernière et avec nous sur notre plateau
jean marie le guen bonjour vous êtes
député du parti socialiste de paris vous
fait campagne pour le retour de
dominique strauss kahn dont vous êtes
l'un des fils est l'un des plus proches
collaborateurs aussi vous allez donc
pouvoir nous parler de cette petite
phrase d'anne sinclair dans le magazine
le point vous êtes aussi médecin
spécialiste des questions de santé et
avec vous bien sûr nous allons aborder
cette question importante de la loi sur
la bioéthique à l'assemblée nationale et
évidemment on va d'abord vous demandez
une première réaction à cette
information
de fin de semaine le départ du président
moubarak il a quitté le pouvoir c'était
incontournable inévitable oui c'était
inévitable
une page est en train de se tourner en
egypte aussi après la tunisie mais
finalement dans le monde arabe et
peut-être même au-delà
ce qui est en train de se passer est
tout à fait exceptionnel c'est quelque
chose que nous avons connue pour les
plus âgés d'entre nous à la fin des
années 80 avec l'effondrement du mur
de berlin et là c'est un mur
psychologique qui est en train de tomber
en même temps qu'un mur politique dans
ces pays dictatoriaux on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en reparler c'est quelque
chose de très important plein d'avenir
il y aura des allées des retours des
avancées des succession des crises
vraisemblablement mais en tout état de
cause c'est fondamental c'est un
nouvelle approche des pays arabes qui
nous faut voir aujourd'hui parlent de
changement mais c'est quand même omar
souleiman qui a été vraiment l'homme de
la politique de sony moubarak et qui te
prend les rênes bien sûr et sans doute
l'armé derrière pèse également mais on
voit bien que ce pouvoir là pour la
première fois est obligé de composer
avec l'exigence démocratique et quelque
part l'exigence démocratique a pris le
leadership des opinions arabes
celles qui ont vraiment changé le monde
et qui demain vont pouvoir changer leur
pays est sans doute je l'espère en tout
cas apporter d'abord la démocratie en
tout cas une certaine forme de
démocratie
et deuxièmement ce qui ira avec je
l'espère une certaine forme de progrès
de justice et bien ceci a été rendu
possible par le mouvement démocratique
on s'attendait la plupart des experts
souvent les occidentaux vous voyez
l'alternant alternative entre un pouvoir
islamique volontiers radical et de
l'autre côté un pouvoir dictatorial qui
aurait été plus compatible avec les
normes internationales et surgit autre
chose qui vient apporter une nouvelle
donne qui est plein d'espoir jean-marie
le guen le président du fait que c'était
inéluctable
vous aussi vous êtes sur cette position
hosni moubarak devait partir oui bien
sûr moi je ne confonds pas d'ailleurs
complètement monsieur moubarak avec
monsieur ben ali monsieur ben ali était
un gangster trop longtemps fréquenté
monsieur moubarak est quelqu'un qui a
fait vraisemblablement un ou deux
mandats de trop et qui sur la fin devant
l'incapacité à résoudre les problèmes
des aspirations démocratiques et
sociales est devenu de plus en plus
dictatorial est de plus en plus
improductif pour son propos mais nous
sommes calmes à sienne fortune
considérable la wii j'ai appris ça
non mais je veux dire par là moubarak
est un homme qui a eu une histoire c'est
aussi l'homme de la paix au moyen-orient
ça a été une certaine forme quand même
de de modération dans les rues ni
international occidentaux en tout cas
oui mais pas simplement pas simplement
il a été aussi un défenseur d'une ligne
intéressante par exemple de l'autorité
palestinienne donc c'est pas je pense
que c'est une vision rétrospective un
peu courte de ne le voir que comme un
dictateur ou comme un allié des
occidentaux il a été aussi un personnage
dans un monde arabe qui c'est le
nationalisme arabe qui a été en son
temps celui qui a porté le mouvement la
décolonisation et porter les espoirs
d'une des peuples et des masses arabes a
été incapable de s'épanouir parce qu'il
a été incapable de résoudre la question
démocratique et la question sociale est
donc ce nationalisme arabe s'est
refermée on le voit en egypte en voit
dans d'autres pays par exemple la syrie
mais d'autres encore il ce nationalisme
a été incapable d'avancer parce que
incapables de dominer la question
démocratique et la question sociale est
bien là on a l'impression que c'est le
mouvement démocratique qui vient prendre
pendant 30 ans d'obscurantisme
la relève des espoirs des masses arabes
quelle va être la place de la france
dans le au proche orient et par rapport
à l'egypte aujourd'hui écoutés nous
avons mal géré ce tournant c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'on l'a
non seulement pas vu venir et à la
limite soyons modestes mais nous ne
l'avons pas senti où il se passait et
pire encore on s'est plutôt mis du côté
des obstacles que du reste donc j'allais
dire nous sommes très mal parti mais au
delà des erreurs du gouvernement
je pense qu'il existe des liens objectif
historique géographique entre la france
et les pays arabes qui fera que nous
avons vocation à converger à travailler
ensemble pour le développement pour la
paix pour la coopération
donc je constate les erreurs mais je ne
je pense que l'avenir est quand même
positif pour nous ne plus avoir comme
voisins puisque la tunisie l'egypte les
pays arabes sont la méditerranée n'est
pas une frontière infranchissable
de plus avoir des voisins qu'ils soient
soient dictatoriaux soit profondément
dangereux comme peut l'être un islamisme
radical c'est quand même une perspective
très très joyeuse très enthousiasmante
je ne néglige pas je ne suis pas naïf je
ne néglige pas les moments de retour en
arrière d'affrontements de difficultés
que nous connaîtrons sur marie le guen
on va passer à l'actualité française
après avoir parlé de l'actualité
internationale et lundi évidemment c'est
la grogne des magistrats qui sont tes
filles
et il aura suffi d'une petite phrase de
nicolas sarkozy fustigeant leur faute et
menaçant les magistrats de sanctions
dans l'affairé laetitia
pour déclencher une véritable tempête un
mouvement sans précédent dans les
tribunaux c'est un reportage de patrick
armand scène le vent de la fronde des
magistrats est parti d'ici du tribunal
de nantes
aujourd'hui ils touchent des dizaines de
palais de justice les raisons de la
colère sont partout les mêmes
des propos d'un président de la
république jugé scandaleux méprisant
état d'esprit des magistrats vous l'avez
compris c'est l'exaspération
c'est l'exaspération face à au
comportement d'un récidiviste le
président de la république il en est pas
à sa première attaque des magistrats il
ya une forme de mépris des institutions
par le président de la république
je pense qu'il est largement temps de
lui appliquer la peine plancher puisque
il faut être
il faut être très dur envers les
multirécidivistes qui est responsable de
l'état dans lequel nous sommes dans quel
est l'état de la justice aujourd'hui
qui est responsable du fait qu'on peut
pas faire bien notre travail si c'est
nous va très bien mais qu'on nous
explique comment il faut faire avec des
dossiers qu'on ne peut pas traiter parce
qu'on n'a pas tant les traiter la ligne
de défense des magistrats c'est
l'absence chronique de moyens pour
rendre la justice
nous avons un vrai problème de moyens
pour lutter contre la récidive notamment
et je crois que les magistrats en ont
assez d'être pris pour cible des
carences du pouvoir exécutif dans la
politique en matière de sécurité avec un
peu plus de 7 milliards d'euros de
budget pour la justice la france est au
37e rang sur 43 pays membres du conseil
de l'europe
un chiffre que l'on retrouvera sans
doute sur les banderoles jeudi dans les
manifestations
jean-marie le guen nicolas sarkozy pour
vous est il allé trop loin avec les
magistrats
non seulement pour moi mais pour
l'ensemble des magistrats aux
pratiquement et je crois pour l'opinion
publique
vraiment vous savez il peut y avoir des
difficultés dans un gouvernement on peut
avoir une insatisfaction budgétaire les
difficultés et monsieur sarkozy à ce
chic particulier de rajouter de la
polémique et de l'acide dans les
relations entre français il déstabilise
une institution aussi importante que
celle de la magistrature
surtout lorsqu'on prétend comme il
prétend lui avoir une politique de
sécurité
comment peut-on à ce point déstabiliser
la police et la justice c'est totalement
irresponsable ont trouvé jeudi soir une
concertation entre le ministre et la
haye les magistrats on y croit les
magistrats un moment ou un autre vont
retourner faire leur travail j'ai pas de
doute là dessus
mais si vous voulez on est en train de
casser un certain nombre d'institutions
de la république
voilà le président la république ces
attitudes irresponsables totalement
gratuite
si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi on voit bien
ce qu'il ya derrière tout ça personne
n'est dupe
depuis la grand mère qui regardent la
télévision jusqu'au procureur général de
la cour de cassation
tout le monde sait bien qu'il essaye de
faire de la récup grossières comme il
l'a fait déjà de très nombreuses fois
sur des faits divers
et d'expliquer que ce n'est pas sa
responsabilité mais la responsabilité
des autres lectures pardon une lecture
allant vers un peu où on a pu entendre
les magistrats ont profité ont exploré
telle affaire laëtitia pour falloir
mouvement on a pu entendre ça c'est une
lecture animée entre le drame de cette
jeune fille et le mouvement des
magistrats il ya le discours monsieur
sarkozy le chaînon sarkozy qui vient
faire exploser toutes les situations
cher que que les magistrats eux-mêmes se
pose des questions sur la manière dont
fonctionnent leurs systèmes que les
pouvoirs publics que le gouvernement est
un débat avec les magistrats en leur
disant peut-être vous n'avez pas assez
de moyens mais vous même est ce que vous
êtes bien organisée etc
vous savez on a on aura ces questions là
mais la manière dont on fait exploser au
lieu d'aller dans le dialogue dans la
discussion dans la concertation dans
l'accompagnement des gens c'est
justement ça ce que les français ne
veulent plus ça dépasse le problème de
la gauche et la droite et je ne suis pas
moi en train d'entonner le discours
corporatiste des magistrats en
l'occurrence vous avez vu d'ailleurs que
la police avait suivi le mouvement
donc et des services pénitentiaires
donc si vous voulez c'est vraiment un
problème de gouvernance bon et vous avez
comme moi parce que vous êtes une
analyste politique vous avez suivi la
séquence pendant deux mois j'essaye de
rester bien calme comme on me l'a
conseillé de ne pas en rajouter dans la
polémique
et puis dès qu'il se passe quelque chose
tout d'un coup je me retiens pas bing en
est une alors à l'autre etc
il a craqué ce que c'est que c'est à
dire bien sûr qu'il a craqué voilà il a
craqué hier soir hop
il nous fait une une émission lénifiant
tout est seulement voilà on voit bien
les hauts et les bas
tout ça est très triste allez va passer
au mardi et on va s'intéresser aux
vacances de noël de françois fillon
c'est une habile stratégie de
communication en ce mardi matignon après
les révélations à venir du canard
enchaîné sur les vacances de noël du
premier ministre et décide donc
d'anticiper l'information oui françois
fillon a bien été hébergé aux frais du
gouvernement égyptien
il a aussi bénéficié d'un vol intérieur
et d'une sortie sur le nil
explication évidemment diversement
appréciée à l'assemblée où se trouve
alors le premier ministre marion le
faire dans un souci de transparence
c'est ainsi que le premier ministre
justifie le communiqué et surtout ses
vacances de fin d'année en egypte à
peine françois fillon quittent
l'hémicycle le communiqué publié
quelques heures avant la parution du
canard enchaîné le premier ministre
apporte des précisions il s'est rendu en
egypte à l'invitation des autorités
locales
il a payé son déplacement privé mais
reconnaît avoir été hébergé par les
autorités égyptiennes et avoir emprunté
un avion de la flotte gouvernementale
locale sur invitation pour la majorité
ces égards sont dues au statut de
premier ministre même dans le cadre d'un
déplacement privé et refuser
l'invitation amical d'un pays étranger
lorsqu'on est premier ministre que cette
invitation est lancée par le président
égyptien sur qui s'appuie la france est
ce que ce ne serait pas une forme
d'affront à l'egypte tout entière et
bien je le dis je pense que françois
fillon eut raison d'accepter cette
invitation et aurait eu tant de la
reprise
l'opposition ne le voit pas de cet oeil
en pleine tempête sur les vacances
tunisiennes de michèle alliot marie
elle dénonce un mélange des genres tout
ceci n'est que l'expression de relations
incestueuses entre un gouvernement qui
se prétend démocratique et exportateurs
des droits de l'homme et puis qui les
passent par profits et pertes lorsqu'il
s'agit de d'aller bronzer sur le soleil
de la méditerranée entre les jets de
l'état contre les jets deux amis hommes
d'affaires contre les jets d etat
étrangers tout est bon pour enceinte
donc le très forts de ceux qui
gouvernent aujourd'hui la france la
gauche en appelle à l'éthique
ces invitations lors de déplacements
privés des ministres ne passe pas et
cadrent mal avec la république
irréprochable prônée par nicolas sarkozy
alors nicolas sarkozy a dit jeudi soir
qu'il n'y avait pas une faute il a
excusé sont faibles indique son premier
ministre n'avait n'avait pas fait de
faute
vous même au ps vous avez été beaucoup
moins virulent que sur la sphère de
michèle alliot marie en tunisie
oui pour plusieurs raisons parce
qu'encore une fois moubarak
c'est pas ben ali et parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu déjà des précédents
mais ce que ne comprend pas ce
gouvernement je parle pas des attitudes
plus problématique vis-à-vis de la
tunisie
mais s'agissant d'une façon générale
moi je vois deux choses premièrement
les membres du gouvernement n'ont pas
l'air de comprendre dans quel état vit
la france et j'allais dire qu'une
certaine forme d'évolution des rapports
cette affaire est arrivé à monsieur tony
blair en 2003 jeu tony blair à
rembourser non pas au gouvernement
égyptien mais à des oeuvres sociales
égyptien le coût de son voyage lorsqu'il
a été interpellé jeudi que c'est depuis
on a une évolution de l'opinion publique
qui est plus exigeante qui comprend
moins un certain nombre de choses
premièrement deuxièmement monsieur
moubarak et j'ai dit tout à l'heure des
choses qui le relativiser j'allais dire
le rôle politique qui a été le sien dans
toute l'histoire le rôle de monsieur
moubarak depuis maintenant quelques
années mais singulièrement dans les mois
qui viennent de se passer on n'avait pas
besoin d'attendre des événements y avait
un trouble à ce moment là non madame
mais vous avez remarqué qu'il ya eu des
élections qui ont été fortement
contestée vous avez remarqué aussi qui a
eu des problèmes intérieurs très fort
par exemple lié aussi à l'église copte
avec des attitudes du pouvoir qui était
relativement ambiguë
vous avez aussi remarquer que toutes les
autorités internationales regretté la
situation à l'intérieur de l'egypte
c'est à dire que la situation s'est
profondément dégradée dans tous ces
sujets là et je pense que la prudence
politique était de ne pas forcément
aller à ce moment-là enneigé le royans
l'institution nicolas sarkozy a fixé un
cadre il a dit il faut privilégier les
vacances en france et si on pas remettre
ça à la vie et du du premier ministre et
de la cellule diplomatique
l'affichage au super que ça c'est
quasiment pitoyable durant transporter
le débat de savoir si on doit aller être
invité par un dictateur ou 1/2 dictateur
en il faut rester vous restez en faut
pas rester en france comme si le
problème avait été d'être à l'aise
d'aller à l'étranger c'est pas ça le
sujet c'est comment on y va et pourquoi
on y va et à quel moment on y va bon et
puis alors monsieur sarkozy l' arbitre
des élégances si vous voulez peut
comprendre aussi que le présent la
république a trouvé utile d'aller juste
après son élection passer des vacances
sur le yacht de monsieur bolloré on peut
comprendre que le premier ministre ou
que le ministre des affaires étrangères
et des repères par rapport à l'éthique
qui sont pas directement fixé dans le
marbre
oui jean sulem une vieille tradition
française ces vacances de luxe ans mais
je viens en son temps de france et du
monde
oui ça ne passe plus pour les français
s'ils pensent que ça ne passe plus pour
les français bon premièrement
deuxièmement c'est pas moubarak qui a 20
ans et pas moubarak il ya un mois où il
ya trois mois où il ya six mois
et troisièmement les liens entre fillon
et moubarak n'étaient pas les liens
entre mitterrand et moubarak mais voilà
et puis ça change et maintenant il ya
des exigences et ses exigences faut les
comprendre
je fais je suis en plus de la politique
que de la morale si je peux me permettre
voilà juste de la politique au sens on
écoute ce que nous disent nos
concitoyens on regarde le monde alors
justement à propos des socialistes qui
n'aurait guère de leçons données en
matière de politique de république
irréprochable
je vous propose d'écouter michèle alliot
marie qui était dans l'hémicycle mardi
alors qu'elle venait d'être encore
interpellé sur ses vacances tunisiennes
en coûte
si monsieur ben ali était infréquentable
pourquoi avez vous attendu son départ et
même trois jours après pour l'exclure de
l'internationale socialiste
si monsieur bnl
et ses amis était infréquentable
pourquoi avez vous invité mi novembre
deux membres de son parti à paris au
conseil de l'international et si vous
êtes blessé mais pas trace il pourquoi
n'excluez vous pas monsieur gbagbo et
son parti alors que monsieur gbagbo ou
si vous ne répondez quoi
d'abord elle et il vaut mieux que dans
la situation est la sienne c'est inutile
de rajouter de l'arrogance mais relève
ans et parfois l'attaquent
oui mais pas papa de cette façon nous
semble-t-il en tout cas moi je ne reçois
pas son attaque pour le reste bien sûr
l'internationale socialiste qui était un
club européen et qui à ce complexe
d'être un club européen a eu parfois la
main un suffisamment lourdes pour
exclure des gens qui en son temps avait
demandé leur adhésion et tout mécanisme
d'exclusion était trop lourd et c'est
absolument clair que l'internationale
socialiste pas le parti socialiste
français n'a pas mis en oeuvre
l'exclusion qu'il aurait fallu du rcd
notamment tunisiens mais voilà avec une
espèce de complexe mal classé de savoir
si oui ou non un club entre guillemets
d'européens doit être ou non tolérant
vis-à-vis de partie au nez c'est quand
même pas suffisamment de rigueur sur
nappe est assez regardant notamment par
exemple sur la sphère gbagbo oui bah
aujourd'hui la question de gbagbo peut
se poser encore c'est encore une toute
autre histoire dont on verra dans
quelques semaines dans quelques mois
comment elle évolue
et comment elle est jugée y compris par
les africains vous vous sentez au clair
sur l'internationale socialiste et par
rapport à ce que disait monsieur lahoud
je suis pas au clair sur
l'internationale socialiste à partir du
moment où vous savez les français ont
une tendance
à avoir mesuré tout à leur propre
monsieur tony blair et dans
l'internationale socialiste il a fait
des choses avec lesquelles je suis en
profond désaccord comme l'intervention
en irak
donc si vous voulez l'internationale
socialiste fonctionne d'une façon non
mais je ne vous dis pas le contraire je
veux bien montrer je montre j'avais dire
les faiblesses de cette internationale
socialiste en même temps en même temps
je pense que nous ne sommes pas comme un
certain nombre de partis membres du ppe
qui ont des facilités un peu grande avec
des partis xénophobes en europe si vous
voulez donc c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on franchit les frontières on
peut être parfois comptable et on est
toujours trop de partis qui ont des
attitudes qui ne sont pas positives long
du mât qui va faire s'occuper la défense
de laurent gbagbo personnalité je veux
dire à son prof oui mais vous savez bien
roland dumas ce monsieur d'abord assez
âgés et qui a un goût particulier pour
la provocation
voilà ça fait avec son confrère
ils étaient tous les deux à l'image de
cheikh m vers 96 mons et les
spécialistes de la provocation c'est une
petite question rapide sur ces trois
députés ump qui ont failli aller à
l'invitation laurent gbagbo en tout cas
d'un de ses proches
en côte d'ivoire ce qui montre sanguine
extremis
j'entends bien et ce qui montre
simplement que la situation
indépendamment de la position qui est la
mienne qui est celle des organismes
internationaux qui disent que les
élections étant ce qu'elle est elle ne
se les reconnaître le résultat des
élections en gbagbo devait reconnaître
le résultat des élections indépendamment
de cette question de principe
la réalité de la situation ivoirienne
sera un jour peut-être nous semble-t-il
décrite de façon plus complexe j'espère
sûrement pas du tout tranché sur cette
question mais je moi je n'ai pas un jeu
je pense alors que ça aurait pu arriver
des députés socialistes
non je crois pas qu'ils aient les
députés socialistes qui aujourd'hui ray
pouvoir laurent gbagbo puisque à ma
connaissance tous quelle que soit leur
position sur la situation en côte
d'ivoire et leurs attaches plutôt du
côté de ouattara ou des attaches à dire
plus neutres ou même proche de laurent
gbagbo
aucun d'entre eux ne s'est opposé au
fait que le résultat des élections
devaient être validées
aucun d'entre nous ne l'a fait par
contre par contre les racines des
problèmes qui existent en côte d'ivoire
mais si c'est simplement un dictacteur
qui surnage au dessus d'une d'une masse
général d'ivoiriens qui sait bien que
c'est plus complexe quoi voilà est
toujours mardi cette fois on va au sénat
un nouveau président pour le groupe
centriste
après le départ de nicolas vous pour le
sait ça c'est françois zocchetto proche
de jean arthuis qui a été élu
d'habitude ce groupe au sénat a
l'habitude de jouer les arbitres je vous
propose de trouver cette élection et
comment ça fonctionnait avec aurélien
ramano il n'aura pas la tâche facile
françois zocchetto élu ce matin
président du groupe centriste le
sénateur de la mayenne devra préserver
l'unité fragile d'un groupe soumis à des
forces contradictoires lors le groupe de
l'union centriste est un groupe
divers c'est ce qui fait notre richesse
la difficulté est en effet d' exprimer
des positions claires et le plus souvent
commune i mode m ni nouveau centre
françois zocchetto est membre de
l'alliance centriste de jean arthuis son
positionnement pourrait satisfaire l'ump
dont la majorité toute relative au sénat
a besoin de l'appui du centre pour
préserver la politique majoritaire on
est dans une logique majoritaire il ya
au sein du groupe ces réalités notamment
du modem qui s'étend sur toute logique
et gauche et droite comme jean marie
vianney père difficiles de la vie
politique des centristes
c'était le sénat qui a été un peu le
signe de la reconstruction de la
reconstruction au niveau national
passera peut-être par la confédération
voulue par hervé morin et jean arthuis
est proposée ce soir à jean louis borloo
jean marie le guen le sénat c'est
toujours un objectif pour la gauche même
si on sent ici au sénat les sénateurs
socialistes qui nous disent on
l'impression pour martine aubry c'est
peut-être pas l'atout majeur où l'enjeu
majeur en l'enjeu majeur il est normal
en république c'est l'élection du
président de la république mais le sénat
est une institution très importante et
c'est vrai que la gauche ce serait un
événement historique qu'elles puissent
être majoritaires alors qu'on sait que
le mode de scrutin la des avantages très
largement ce qui présuppose sais que ça
va jouer a très peur
paraît-il oui voila j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir et en même temps faut savoir
être aussi réaliste nous verrons bien
eh bien on va passer au mercredi avec le
texte sur la bioéthique qui arrive à
l'assemblée changements majeurs
c'est une règle la loi sur la bioéthique
de 1994 doit être périodiquement réviser
le texte est donc revenue cette semaine
à l'assemblée la bioéthique c'est un
champ très vaste des mères porteuses à
la recherche sur l'embryon et on va le
voir elle qu aurélie marcireau il n'y a
pas eu dans cette nouvelle mouture
d'audace particulière pas de révolution
vue en matière de bioéthique cette
semaine dans l'hémicycle refuser les
mères porteuses
le débat sur la gestation pour autrui
fait rage dans la société
mais le sujet n'est pas évoquée dans la
loi la grande majorité des députés ils
sont opposés
la discussion a lieu par le biais
d'amendements déposés par des élus verts
mais sans espoir d'évolution du texte
refusé l'accès aux origines pour les
enfants des grâce à un don de gamète
sperme ou ovocyte
roselyne bachelot ministre de la santé
lors de la rédaction du texte étaient
pour
comme de nombreux députés finalement
revirement la commission a repoussé
cette possibilité les élus craignent un
effondrement des dons concernant le don
d'ovocytes cette fois la loi procède à
quelques aménagements qui n'empêcheront
certainement pas des milliers de femmes
de partir à l'étranger chaque année pour
bénéficier d'un an toujours refusé la
pma pour les couples homosexuels
en revanche pour les couples
hétérosexuels être pacsé suffira
désormais pour bénéficier des techniques
de procréation médicalement assistée
seule audace des parlementaires
l'ouverture contre l'avis du
gouvernement de la possibilité de
transfert d'embryon post mortem dans un
temps limité une veuve pourrait
bénéficier d'un transfert d'embryons
créés du vivant du père mais les députés
de droite votent ils allaient jusqu'à
beauté dans l'hémicycle contre l'avis du
gouvernement
à voir le débat entre droite et gauche
reprendra ses droits sur la question de
la recherche sur l'embryon
elles restent interdites par principe
mais toujours autorisés en pratique la
gauche veut la levée de l'interdiction
la droite son maintien les députés
s'affronteront donc sur une question de
principe
alors jean marie le guen quand on disait
pas d'audace particulière je vous
entends dire c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
comment expliquer qu'il ait si peu
d'avancé sur ce texte tout simplement
parce que d'une part il y a à
l'intérieur de la droite des gens qui
pour des raisons
philosophique et en l'occurrence
religieuses sont tout à fait opposés à
toute avancée dans le domaine de la
bioéthique et un gouvernement qui sans
forcément croire à cela a décidé pour
des raisons purement politiciennes de
faire des concessions à cette aile
conservatrice avec roselyne bachelot
était plutôt pour une avancée bienvenue
ans mais que là on ya des
présidentielles il faut il faut ménager
un électorat catholique est sans doute
le calcul de monsieur sarkozy
mais il faut savoir les français ne le
savent pas c'est que l'interdiction de
la recherche sur l'embryon c'est non
seulement des pertes de chance pour des
malades mais c'est une perte de chance
pour notre pays de façon considérable en
matière de recherche nous sommes en
train de nous priver véritablement d'un
des rôles majeurs de la france c'est à
dire le découvreur dans les sciences du
vivant et là nous sommes en train et on
est possible avec dérogations oui c'est
dire qu'elle est instable c'est à dire
que vous ne pouvez pas véritablement
quand vous êtes une équipe de chercheurs
voire un des laboratoires installés dans
la durée la certitude que vous allez
pouvoir planifier à chaque fois il
faudra passer des mois pour discuter
avec des commissions qui peuvent être un
moment ou un autre sensible à la
position du gouvernement et on ne sait
pas qui c'est donc si vous laissez
moment non mais c'est très très grave on
discute c'est à la fois une question de
principe parce que c'est vraiment de
l'obscurantisme kate est édictée dans la
loi française l'obscurantisme le retour
de l'obscurantisme et deuxièmement c'est
véritablement une perte de chance pour
les malades et une perte de chance pour
la recherche française
donc je lève un tout petit peu le taux
parce que je dois vous dire que c'est
une décision très grave sur les autres
aspects des moeurs
moi je les choses n'ont pas changé les
choses sont allées voter socialiste
wallon ya eu des débats au parti
socialiste sûr qu'il ya des débats des
choses ne s'est pas d'accord sur tout
non sur la recherche sur l'embryon tout
le monde est d'accord
à gauche tout le monde est d'accord sur
les questions touchant aux moeurs il ya
des débats parce que il ya des
interprétations
on peut avoir les mêmes valeurs et avoir
une lecture opposé par exemple sur le
nom de galles
oui moi j'étais pour hercules et ça oui
absolument parce que je ne suis pas sûr
cette position moi je suis sur une
position d'ouverture très très structuré
on va dire très très très contrainte
parce que je comprends la crainte de la
marchandisation ce qui est vraiment un
problème tout à fait important je pense
qu'on peut le bloquer je ne crois pas à
l'idée qu'il faut développer une théorie
générale de la du risque de la
marchandisation cirque on a des verrous
ça va c'est pas la peine de construire
des murs les enceintes etc
je pense que les verrous suffirait
largement à éviter cela et a contrario
on ne reconnaît pas au nom de cette
crainte
à mon avis exagérer on ne reconnaît pas
le droit à des femmes qui sont dans
l'impossibilité de porter l'enfant par
exemple elles n'ont pas d'utérus pour
des raisons y compris médical notamment
médicale tout simplement d'avoir
un enfant avec les autres sites qui sont
les siens et le sperme et les
spermatozoïdes de son conjoint
donc voilà je trouve ça dommage que
que le parlement n'avance pas mais vous
avez raison de dire que là dessus le
parti socialiste pour des raisons que je
comprends mais pour des raisons que je
ne partage pas a pris cette position
très rapide comme comme réponse il n'y
aura plus de révision des lois
bioéthiques ça a été abandonnée c'est
pas une très mauvaise décision non je
pense que c'est une bonne chose
paradoxalement parce que je pense que
nous serons de plus en plus dans la
bioéthique
c'est à dire que plus pour l'encadrer je
pense que nous serons amenés dans pas
longtemps à avoir une loi annuel
comme il ya des lois de financement si
vous voulez on dit la finance pas elle
est la science est en train d'exploser
on parlera beaucoup de la génétique
autour de la problématique de la
bioéthique ou des greffes ou de la fin
de vie on va bientôt parler des
neurosciences c'est un débat qui va
exploser parce que la science est là et
j'espère que la france j'ai quelques
craintes avec ce gouvernement mais
j'espère que la france prendra aussi ce
virage il ya des explosions
scientifiques qui vont poser des
questions éthiques
c'est loin contournable oui oui ça j'en
connais beaucoup de bioéthique dans les
années qui viennent et peut-être pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle
mais plus précisément de ce signe venu
de washington c'est le magazine le point
qui consacre sa une à dominique strauss
kahn et on apprend par la voix de son
épouse anne sinclair qu'elle ne souhaite
pas un second mandat de son mari à la
tête du fmi jean marie le guen vous qui
êtes un proche de nemos cannes alors il
va y aller je l'espère et je crois qu'il
ya un certain nombre de signes qui
montrent que les éléments que l'on
donnait sur lequel il ne pourrait pas
venir et notamment par exemple parce que
anne sinclair n'y serait pas favorable
et ces bons qui était tout un tas de
rumeurs entretenues par certains je
pense que anne d'un certain point de vue
pas complètement d'ailleurs puisqu'elle
parle de washington et de paris elle ne
parle pas des fonctions a quand même
assumer ensemble chose pour sa part qui
sont un signe fort on sait que l'un
d'eux sinclair est à la fois eu
une journaliste et une commentatrice
politique très très fine et donc
lorsqu'il s'exprime il faut l'écouter
mais bon c'est surtout que dominique
strauss kahn ne peut pas s'exprimer et
qu'il fallait trouver quelqu'un pour
cette somme est donc cette anne sinclair
oui mais en même temps je pense que ce
nom c'est pas donc je pense que par
ailleurs anne sinclair peut s'exprimer
plus facilement elle s'exprime mais je
crois pas qu'ils aient je pense qu'il
faut dans tous les commentaires que j'ai
entendus à droite et à gauche
enfin souvent la plupart à droite et
certains à gauche
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait c'était
empreint d'un certain machisme ou en
gros l'épousé n'avait pas le droit de
s'exprimer
le contraire c'est pas un peu macho
passé par sa femme pour sa propre
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait c'est ainsi
c'est cette lecture est erronée je veux
dire que anne sinclair est une personne
que vous connaissez
puisque elle était très visible pour
tous les français elle a sa personnalité
et donc elle a exprimé quelque chose
peut-être en soutien aussi c'est vrai
mais c'est pas c'est pas parce que on
est à côté conte et instruments de ce
qu'a dit françois hollande moi je me
serais pas par moi même je suis clair
sur mes intentions ça veut dire qu'il ne
s'exprime pas par lui-même qu'il n'est
pas clair son attention
vous comprenez que ça puisse quand même
agacé cette façon de tergiverser de
jijel pas dire qu'on y va non il ne
tergiverse pas vous c'est tout le monde
sait qu'il ya d'une part un calendrier
démocratique est un cas la république
c'est des élections dans 14 mois la
campagne électorale dans 12
le parti socialiste qui a anticipé un
calendrier aura des primaires à
l'automne et tout le monde sait que
dominique strauss kahn s'exprimera au
début de l'été il dira ce début de l'été
ce qui bat vraisemblablement puisqu'ils
et vous savez que le dépôt des
candidatures pour les primaires c'est
entre le 28 juin et le 13 juillet donc
on sera s'il est candidat ou s'il ne
l'est pas donc ça c'est tout à fait
clair pour le reste je trouve que je
parmi les commentaires que je trouvais
un peu machiste et un peu désagréable il
avait celui effectivement de françois je
trouve que en général il a des
commentaires ces derniers mois un petit
peu plus en phase avec la réalité
sociale et je trouve ça inutile
il était prochain c'est ce pas un peu
tard c'est le cas pour martine aubry par
exemple on a vu à dakar qu'elle prenait
un peu au bout à un statut de
présidentiable
vous pensez qu'elle va pouvoir attendre
jusqu'à l'été 2
savoir quel sera le bon vouloir de son
rival principal rival ou alliés selon je
ne traite pas sûr que d'abord elle
attendre avant l'été peut-être qu'il
aura des informations avant et
deuxièmement c'est elle même qui a fixé
le calendrier donc je pense que l a pas
de problème avec ça
bon si vous le dites alors on passe à
jeudi quand le sénat détricote le texte
sur l'immigration
le sénat vote ce jeudi en première
lecture le texte sur l'immigration et en
la matière les sénateurs ont encore
marqué leur différence par rapport aux
intentions du ministre plusieurs mesures
phares ont été supprimés comme la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
auteurs de crimes contre les forces de
l'ordre
tout cela nous est expliqué par sandra
cerqueira un travail d'assouplissement
qui a commencé en commission et s'est
poursuivie dans l'hémicycle dix jours
d'examen et un texte voté mais de
justesse avec quelques changements et
surtout un revers pour le gouvernement
sur l'extension de la déchéance de
nationalité
c'est ensemble que la gauche et le
centre ont voté contre cette mesure
voulue par nicolas sarkozy
ça fait partie de ces lois finalement
qui sont des véhicules de communication
mais qui ne servent à rien
qui dans certains cas pourrait créer des
apatrides ce qui est indigne
autres modifications apportées sur les
mariages gris cette fois la gauche n'en
voulait pas finalement l'article est
conservé mais les sénateurs ont maintenu
les cinq ans d'emprisonnement et les
15000 euros d'amendé prévue dans la loi
actuelle le droit au séjour médical pour
les étrangers malades est également
maintenue c'est une des fonctions du
sénat c'est d'être le défenseur des
libertés fondamentales de la
constitution du droit très discutée en
séance la procédure de rétention des
sans-papiers
le sénat rejette l'article qui vise à
faire passer le juge administratif avant
le juge des libertés
une réforme que le rapporteur juge
nécessaire il l'a défendu jusqu'au bout
avantage du texte août
et au juge administratif il n'est pas en
contradiction avec le juge de l'allier
de la liberté d'attention que le juge
judiciaire
donc il ya une complémentarité
d'ailleurs les deux interviennent sur
des sujets totalement différent reste à
savoir désormais si l'assemblée
nationale reviendra sur ce vote en
seconde lecture
alors on attend effectivement la seconde
lecture à l'assemblée on al'impression
on peut que l'opposition au sein de la
majorité le podium ya plus du sénat que
de l'assemblée l'intérieur de la
majorité
c'est clair que le sénat a la volonté de
s'exprimer y compris dans la droite
c'est à dire chez où les chez les
centristes qui appartient à la majorité
peut-être j'y vois là une certaine forme
de tradition de distance et de sagesse
du sénat en tout cas c'est souvent le
terme qui les emploient pour se
qualifier
qualifié leur travail j'y vais aussi
peut-être la pression d'une gauche qui
seraient aux portes de prendre la
présidence du sénat est certain les
élections à bonjour voilà la peur et qui
souvent bonne conseillère voyez donc
peur d'une majorité potentielle de
gauche amène peut-être certains
sénateurs loi
nous avons notre indépendance voilà mais
c'est leur jeu c'est bien normal est en
tout cas la démocratie et en
l'occurrence et alors cette demi-heure
de la france qui gagne
cette deuxième lecture à l'assemblée
nationale la gauche on peut l'attendre
un petit peu est-ce qu'elle va se
mobiliser comme c'était le cas en
première lecture à l'assemblée
oui bien sûr malheureusement que vous le
savez nous ne sommes pas majoritaires
donc j'ai auprès des associations qui
avaient manifesté et largement vers la
rue je pense que oui a reconnu peut-être
sûrement mais mais aussi au parlement ce
qui est quand même notre première tâche
jeu
non ça fait beaucoup de mal à la france
si c'est un peu comme la sphère des
magistrats c'est des trucs totalement et
qui blesse un certain nombre de gens et
qui blesse l'image de la france c'est
des faux problèmes des fausses
polémiques en l'occurrence plus grave
certainement sur la sphère des des
étrangers que sur la sphère des
magistrats le magistrat voudront bien
excuser mes propos mais mais encore plus
grave j'entends dans la blessure les
conséquences humaines pas forcément dans
les conséquences institutionnelles mais
mais voilà ces traits ou perd son temps
c'est des polémiques inutiles la france
n'avance pas c'est vraiment il faut
rassembler les français on a besoin
aujourd'hui d'être solidaire d'avancé on
voit bien qu'on que qu'une des grandes
échéances sont là que nous sommes plutôt
en retard qu'il faut saisir cela là
vraiment c'est vraiment beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie perdue et une
image de la france et cornet allait
repasser à jeudi soir nicolas sarkozy
était face aux français sur tf1 un gros
toral ppe-de annonce si ce n'est
peut-être sur la lutte contre le chômage
500 millions d'euros débloqués notamment
pour les contrats aidés
on écoute tout de suite président de la
république et on réagit juste avec votre
invité
nous avons décidé avec le premier
ministre aujourd'hui
budget du ministre de l'emploi un demi
milliard d'euros pour consacrer ce
budget sur deux catégories de français
qui ont besoin qu'on les aide les
chômeurs de longue durée
nous allons dégager cet argent qui va
nous permettre de faire recevoir dans
les trois mois tous les chômeurs de
longue durée et de proposer à tous les
chômeurs de longue durée soit une
formation qualifiante soit un emploi à
jean marie le guen
avec cette annonce pour les emplois
aidés c'est quand même qu' un petit bon
pour vous pouvez lui accorder à nicolas
sarkozy non on connaît cette politique
celle à peu nicolas sarkozy a critiqué
de façon radicale en disant vraiment les
emplois aidés c'est la négation de ce
qu'il faut pour l'économie d'ailleurs il
les a massivement supprimé pendant les
quatre premières années de son mandat
est là parce que sa politique par
ailleurs est un échec et que idées à la
veille des élections il va faire des
contrats aidés c'est à dire qu'on va
creuser du budget pour faire un emploi
alors pour les personnes qui vont être
en contrat aidé moi je évidemment ça
positif mais c'est vraiment la sanction
de l'échec économique de sa politique
voilà c'est tout sauf une politique
d'avenir bon moi je n'aurais pas eu
cette attitude
j'aurais gérer la problématique des
emplois aidés si vous voulez d'une façon
plus ou moins brutal qu'il ne l'a fait
lorsqu'il était joueur voir ce qu'il a
fait oui bien sûr c'est un mépris du
social donc c'est récupération hier soir
en fait il va bien sûr il se récupère en
dernière année il remet en place la
politique qu'il a honteusement est
largement critiqué au début de son
mandat
bon il compense très bien parfait mais
en même temps c'est l'échec tout ça
moi ce qui m'a frappé dans tous les
interviews de monsieur savait à quoi ils
croient du show sarkozy est ce qu'ils
croient sa propre politique
on voit pas le sens de l'ouïe loire et
je les trouvais même dans la forme
d'ailleurs beaucoup moins dynamique
qu'il l'était précédemment cirque on a
l'impression que cet homme s'endort sauf
quand il se réveille pour lancer une
polémique mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on
va vers la france oui sur la forme que
vous diriez quoi pour cette émission de
jeudi soir c'était barbant regarder
jusqu'au bout quand même avec difficulté
un quand j'en écris aujourd'hui j'ai
regardé un quart d'heure et puis j'ai
arrêté
oui oui je le comprends c'est à dire que
jean luc mélenchon sait pas faire les
efforts nécessaires pour mieux combattre
sarkozy fallait rester un peu plus
longtemps il y avait quand même un panel
de gens qui avait de réels problèmes et
finalement c'est une idée de confronter
comme ça
les français face à un impressionnant
république c'est peut-être formule à
garder c'est quand même pas une formule
très innovante un 13ème en françois
mitterrand l'avait lui-même fait ya
quelques années donc ça ça nous rajeunit
pas complètement et jean marie pernot
non plus donc pas revanche entre ses
parents et un autre genre maritain mais
voilà c'était ça montre quand même je
pense que personnellement je pense que
nous sommes à la fin du système sarkozy
c'est à dire que les ficelles qui
consiste à agiter l'opinion sont
maintenant connus de tous les ressorts
de sa politique les ressorts
idéologiques de sa politique ont été mis
en échec et je pense qu'il a un problème
fondamental de trouver un second souffle
comme il n'a pas su trouver un nouveau
souffle pour son équipe gouvernementale
à l'automne jean-marie le guen a parlé
de beaucoup de choses dures dans cette
émission je peux vous conseiller peut
être une petite exposition si vous en
avez le temps c'est en tout cas jusqu'au
23 mai c'est dans les jardins du
luxembourg
les oeuvres du peintre allemand de la
renaissance lucas cranach
c'est je le disais je
position il ya des labos et 13 aides à
son hôte vous vouliez finir peut-être
sur une petite question curiosité
s'assurer que vous avez dit que vous
verriez bien un grand ensemble
immobilier sur l'avenue foch
on revient on finit au fond au fond de
l'enceinte et sait quelle mouche vous a
piqué 7 c'est un peu provocateur c'est
ce ça le goût de la provocation mais ça
à la texture du sérieux j'ai fait un
texte d'une quinzaine de pages où
j'explique que le logement en ile de
france est une véritable bombe qui va
exploser qui explose tous les jours et
que il faut donc prendre des mesures
tout à fait radicale avec je vous
inviterai pourtant bien vite reparler
mais simplement le l'ouest de paris doit
participer effectivement à bertrand
delanoë a dit qu'il vous a une entière
confiance sur les questions de santé fin
au domaine mais que ce changement
n'était pas encore fait c'est pas grave
parce que mon idée c'est de voir un peu
plus loin aussi
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions était notre invité cette
semaine voire la semaine